did you know that joe biden is more
conservative than donald trump
this thought had never occurred to me
but it apparently did occur
to the former republican senator jeff
flake
who was on speaking to cnn christian
amanpour who drew clavin calls christian
i'm a poor journalist
and he made the bold claim this is a
claim that echoes the same sort of
sentiments
we've heard from the never trumpers
there are like three of them left in
america
who say trump is not a real conservative
so much so
that they're now saying that this
daughtering old shell of a man
who supports abortion on demand up until
birth by taxpayer expense
and suing nuns and forcing mandates on
everybody that that guy
is more conservative than your favorite
president donald trump
well conservatives believe in preserving
and conserving you know institutions
to preserve what we know works and the
institutions of american democracy
are freedom of the press for example or
uh separation of powers independent
judiciary
and the president has shown that he
either little understands or little
appreciates uh
these institutions so i'm not pretending
that uh
joe biden is good as conservative as i
am on fiscal issues and whatnot but uh
but on those important issues
of american democracy uh frankly he's
more conservative than the president is
donald trump doesn't appreciate freedom
of the press
probably the most transparent
administration we've had certainly in my
lifetime
probably in over a hundred years donald
trump doesn't appreciate separation of
powers the most federalist
constitutional president we've had
in my lifetime something tells me that
jeff flake
and many other people not only on the
left but a few on the right as well
don't appreciate how corrupt our press
has become
and how little separation of powers
there is in our government
we will get into the true meaning of
conservatism i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday came from carl
who said my favorite saying about
statistics came from one of my
statistics professors
statistics are like bikinis what they
reveal is enticing
what they hide is essential that is a
profound statement
about statistics we'll get into
statistics a little bit too because
i think conservatives should not play
around with those statistics those
statistics
can be very dangerous things because
statistics themselves
are progressive statistics themselves
are left-wing they are a creation of the
left
only about 100 years ago which we will
get into
is joe biden more conservative than
donald trump
hard to say that he's older he's old
he's an old guy is that what you mean by
conservative that he's older
some people believe that but that's not
all conservatism is
we've been having these debates
certainly since 2016 at
a large scale we've been having them for
much longer than that what does it mean
to be conservative something tells me
what jeff flake means by conservative
is not the same view that would have
been shared by john adams or george
washington or edmund burke or
other other people in the conservative
tradition
what does it mean if we elect joe biden
we are electing the representative of a
political party
that is calling for violence throughout
the country
there was a quick smattering of this put
together that
that was going around twitter yesterday
the actual clip goes on for
several minutes just a little taste of
that conservative political party
we'd be putting into power i i just
don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country and maybe
there will be
people need to start taking to the
streets this is a dictator
you know there needs to be unrest in the
streets for as long as there's unrest in
our lives
enemies of the state show me where it
says that protests are supposed to be
polite and peaceful
do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
when they go low we kick them how do you
resist the temptation to run up and ring
her neck
biggest terror threat in this country
is white men most of them radicalized
right up to the right i thought he
should have punched him in the face i
said even if you lost he insulted your
wife
he came down the escalator and called
mexicans rapism he said well what do you
think i should have done so i think you
should punch him in the face and then
gotten out of the race he would have
been a hero
i'd like to punch him in the face i said
if we were in high school i'd take him
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
him
punch some people in the face when was
the last time
an actor assassinated a president
notice here how seamlessly it moves from
the politicians
to the appointed officials like attorney
general eric holder who said when they
go low we kick him
to the mainstream media the news media
to
hollywood back to the elected
politicians
joe biden himself notice how seamlessly
it all moves because it's all part of
the same thing
how's that for a free press how's that
for separation of powers what are they
all calling for violence violence in the
streets
punching people disregarding the rule of
law is that conservative
of course i mean by definition that's
not conservative you're tearing the
country down
so what do we mean by conservative we'll
get into that in one second first though
got to thank our friends over at
ancestry you know
it's a very cool thing to learn about
your family origins i really have loved
it
even since before the daily wire existed
and i've trusted
ancestry so you can map out your cool
family tree and everything you can find
ancestors you didn't know you had
and then an ancestry dna test tells you
where your ancestors are from
and ancestry's billions of records and
millions of family trees
let you discover their personal stories
you could find a famous relative you
could maybe find a photo of your great
grandma as a little girl one thing i
always liked since we started the show
and since
since ancestry has been supporting the
show i'll get messages on ancestry from
listeners
who it turns out we're like 12th cousins
or something like that because you can
you can find all these things on
ancestry i love it i think if you're a
history buff
if you're interested in conserving
things if you're interested in tradition
there's no better hobby to get into it
will reveal
not just the history of the country the
history maybe of whatever country your
family is from
it will reveal your own personal family
history you can pinpoint
specific regions that people came from
it's just tremendously
cool to look at it and it informs your
own view of yourself
start exploring your family story today
head over to my url
which is ancestry.com knowles
k-n-w-l-e-s
to get your ancestry dna kit start your
free trial
ancestry.com knowles
obviously nothing conservative about
wanting to tear the country down
but you might say oh michael come on
you're pointing to these crazy leftists
like
nancy pelosi who just caught got caught
in a big lie herself we'll get to that
in one second
you're talking about these crazy
leftists like that stranger things guy
out of hollywood
you're not talking about old joe biden
old scranton joe oh
amtrak joe oh he's great he's just my
fun nice little uncle
well for one we did hear joe biden in
that montage of people calling for
unrest for people calling to take to the
streets but also does anybody really
think that if joe biden is elected
president
he's going to be the one calling the
shots
talk about separation of powers joe
biden again yesterday because it was a
day that ended in y
on the few days that his handlers allow
him
to broadcast outside of his basement
he had another big error joe biden was
giving
his typically soaring rhetoric in an
interview with a local nbc affiliate
take a listen to his oratory
what's the president doing look
venezuela's top line message is
president trump's policy is an abject
failure
that's the top-line message for those of
you who are not familiar with
teleprompters
or with with political notes sometimes
you'll see the top-line message that's
the point you've got to drive home but
that's not you don't say the top line
message that's the part that you keep
quiet
and keep in your head unless you don't
know what to say you've forgotten how to
conduct politics
you're not really in control of your
rational faculties and you're just
reading off of a teleprompter
which is obviously what joe biden is
doing
he's not able even to form these
sentences and it's funny because now
you know the left always projects so
whatever is true of them they just
throw on to the other political party
yesterday they were trying to suggest
that trump had
a cognitive decline or he had a stroke
or some something crazy like that
regardless of what you think about trump
you might hate him you might
hate his policies you might be a
conservative and hate him because there
are disagreements among conservatives
one thing we're talking about today
you can't say the guy is senile
the guy will get up and give a
three-hour speech without a teleprompter
and he'll keep the audience engaged for
the whole thing in fact he keeps the
audience more engaged with that a
teleprompter than he does with a
teleprompter but certainly he can read a
teleprompter
the same cannot be said of joe biden
whether you like joe biden or you hate
joe biden
the guy is obviously in decline and so
if you elect him
what are you electing you're electing
the democratic party apparatus
which far from a separation of powers is
this liberal establishment connected to
the media connected to the universities
connected to
hollywood connected to big technology
today connected obviously
to the party itself and they are pushing
a radical message
that involves violence in the streets
that involves tearing down
our institutions and our statues
and the great men that those statues
represent there is nothing
conservative about that at all and the
guy representing that party is not all
there
so how else are they trying to take this
election away
the way the other way i think if you
look at the
polls joe biden did not get the bump he
was trying to get out of picking kamala
harris joe biden did not get the bump he
was trying to get out of the dnc
donald trump did get a bit of a bump
particularly among voters that democrats
need particularly black voters
so they're just trying to steal it at
this point
this is a report from a
bloomberg funded poll group here
uh this is funded by bloomberg is
currently working for a bunch of
pro-biden super pacs trump may win
election night but joe biden will win
days later
because of mail-in votes i have been
telling you that this could happen
for weeks now ever since they
established this regime of nationwide
mail-in votes you know widespread
mail-in votes 80 to 100 million people
expected to vote by mail
that's how you steal elections the
reason we have election day the reason
you have to go to a polling place
the reason insane states that you have
to show an id
to vote is so that we can have ballot
security and protect the integrity of
our ballots because by the way if people
forge a couple ballots
or harvest ballots that should not have
been harvested
then they cancel out your vote right
they cancel out the legitimate vote of
other people
so you could have a situation where on
election night looks like trump's going
to win
because one republicans are more likely
to
go outside of their homes they don't
blindly believe the authority that's
changed its tune on coronavirus every 15
minutes for the past six months
they're more willing to go out there and
republicans
tends not to steal elections in the way
that democrats are stealing elections so
you could have
a trump tsunami on election night and
then two weeks later say ah no the
maryland's oh
that truck of melons came in you know
that one with the biden bumper sticker
on it yeah so it turns out biden's
actually the president
well that's obviously illegitimate but
this is what is being pushed by josh
mendelsohn ceo of hawkfish which is this
group
funded by bloomberg his firm is
predicting a red
mirage that's what they're going to call
it when trump wins the election because
they know at this point
it's looking very good for trump right
now if you look not just even at the
polls but at the betting odds
on real clear politics who's winning the
who's winning where people are actually
putting money down on the line trump has
a one-tenth of a percentage point edge
not a huge edge it's basically a dead
heat
but they're giving the edge to trump
there over in las vegas
so if you're in that kind of situation
where biden has lost a major lead trump
is coming back up now what they're going
to try to do is steal it
is that conservative depends what arrow
it's conservative in the sense of going
back to the democratic party's roots
in community organizing and tammany hall
and political corruption but it's not
conservative
in trying to preserve the
good regime that the founders
established by the way
by the way that whole mail-in ballot
regime that's going to try to steal
these
this election is based on the idea
that you're not allowed to go outside
because you'll die of the coronavirus
people are dropping like flies from
coronavirus
even though only six percent of deaths
are directly attributable to coronavirus
exclusively attributable to coronavirus
that forget about that don't worry some
everyone's at risk even though the
median age of a coronavirus victim is
older than the life expectancy in the
united states
you forget about that healthy people
need to wear masks and stay home and
never go outside and mail in your
ballots
it'll all be fine after november 3rd
well it turns out the people pushing all
that bs
don't believe it themselves
secret security camera footage that's my
favorite story the whole day
secret security camera footage from san
francisco now shows
nancy pelosi the highest ranking
democratic official in the country
walking into a closed hair salon
remember they closed all the businesses
because kova's going to kill us all
walking into that hair salon
without a mask to get her private hair
appointment
because she should be allowed to get
haircuts
just not all those dirty hoy ploy who
have to stay at home until election day
so we can continue fear-mongering the
amazing video
shows you got someone in here you got an
employee probably wearing a mask
then here comes nancy wearing a robe
no mask on the employee behind her also
wearing a mask nancy doesn't need it
though
and nancy by the way is in the high risk
category for coronavirus
and she's one of the people more than
anyone pushing
the hysteria in this country on the
lockdowns but she doesn't believe it
which i've been telling you for months
none of the people pushing this nonsense
believe it
it's only the lemmings who follow along
so what's it all about it's pretty clear
what it's all about it's all about
the election it's all about who we hire
to be our next president
speaking of hiring how's that first
segue i got to thank our friends over at
zip recruiter
you know hiring right now on your own
without assistance is really really hard
it's hard to do it ziprecruiter makes it
so much easier
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job sites but they don't just
stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and actively invites them
to apply to your job this to me is the
game changer here because it's not
just throwing spaghetti at the wall it's
it's not even just
looking at the people who have applied
it's going out there finding the right
candidates for you
time is money in hiring it's very hard
to find the right person ziprecruiter
makes it efficient
and effective they've got screening
questions to filter candidates they've
got an all-in-one dashboard
where you can review and rate your
candidates it's so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
not just any candidate quality candidate
within the first day now unfortunately
we have a couple
daily wire employees here that we hired
before we knew we really knew about zip
recruiter
and that's too bad we're dealing with
that now don't make our mistake okay
right now ziprecruiter you can try it
for free my listeners can go to zip
recruiter dot com slash
knowles ziprecruiter dot com slash
knowledge can w-l-e-s
ziprecruiter.com knowles zip recruiter
is the
smartest way to hire
so of course pelosi doesn't believe this
herself bill de blasio when he shut down
the gyms in new york he didn't shut down
his gym well he did he shut it down for
everybody but himself
and he got caught and he said well i got
to look good i got to work out mayor of
chicago
went and got a haircut after she cut
down the salons
and what was her excuse she said i need
a haircut i i'm a clean person i'm a
public-facing person
well yeah not like all you dirty people
you you dirty
constituents of mine you don't get to go
to the hair salon just me
this whole thing this coronavirus
lockdown
from the very beginning has been a
nakedly political
non-scientific power grab that's all it
is no separation of power is there
it is a grab by the ruling class the
people who want to tell you
how to live your life and who have no
business doing it fortunately some
courageous conservative politicians in
the country
not all so-called conservative
politicians but some of the courageous
ones
are pushing back on this in particular
ron desantis in florida
showing tremendous leadership during
this whole coronavirus pandemic
it's funny because they give all the
credit to andy cuomo who's the worst
governor in
america on coronavirus whose policies
killed thousands of elderly new yorkers
and then they always castigate ron
desantis in florida
who's done an amazing job and whose
policies have defied all the doomsday
predictions
so ron desantis comes out he's talking
about the coronavirus policies
and he makes an emphatic statement that
should be a litmus test for every
republican politician in this country
he said we are never going to do these
kinds of lockdowns
again we understand what we need to do
uh but but we will never do any of these
lockdowns
again and i hear people say they'll shut
down the country and honestly i cringe
because
we know places that have done that the
most draconian lockdown in the world has
been peru military in force since march
they have the highest per capita
mortality
in the world from covet and at best what
a lockdown will do is delay
it does not reduce the ultimate
mortality but i think dr alice would
agree
it creates a lot of other problems with
mortality
that a lot of that a lot of people don't
necessarily focus on
so much information packed into that
statement one you get the
the top line message which is we're
never going to do these lockdowns again
these sort does that mean we can we can
never have any kind of quarantine
policies if there's some truly awful
pandemic no of course not but we're not
doing this again we're not shutting down
the world
over the flu again so then he moves on
from there he says
there's no evidence that the lockdowns
help we talked about this yesterday on
the show
actually there's a study that was just
published by revolver yesterday that
shows that the lockdowns were 10 times
deadlier than the virus itself
in terms of human life years lost
obviously true
there's no evidence that the lockdowns
are particularly effective
the most draconian locked ends in the
world of peru peru has a terrible
experience with coronavirus a country
that basically stayed open the whole
time sweden
we were predicted this was going to
completely destroy the swedish
population
what happened they're doing a lot better
in many ways than their neighbors
so those predictions none of those came
true and then he brings it back
to the philosophical point of it to the
the actual
purpose of the law what was the purpose
of the lockdowns was it to
save lives it wasn't actually
not really it was to
save lives that that could needlessly
have been lost
had we overwhelmed the hospital system
but we never came close to that
the purpose of the lockdowns was to
flatten the curve not
find a cure flatten the curve flatten
the curve below the capacity of the
hospital system
so that you didn't have a situation
where people are dying on the street
because there just weren't enough beds
in the hospitals for instance weren't
enough nurses to go around
we never got even close to that not even
in new york
which in part because of andrew cuomo's
terrible policies was hit the worst
we had the javits center emergency
hospital basically
completely empty we had that hospital
ship that was sent by the federal
government
basically empty unneeded
so none of the arguments for these
lockdowns turned out to be true
what happens when circumstances change
when new evidence presents itself
well good politicians adapt to that and
base their policies on that and power
hungry cynics
who are interested in nothing but the
the amassing of their own
power even at the expense of destroying
the country
like joe biden like nancy pelosi like
the entire democratic party
they don't change their mind because
they're cynical about politics
and it's it's not even that they're
liars it's that they just don't care
about the truth
not one way or the other what what
desantis is doing which by the way was
criticized
by some of those egghead conservative
politicians you know
the ones who they're very sophisticated
they're fancy they're republicans but
they're not that kind of republican
oh they're sensible they listen to
statistics they're they're they love the
experts
please don't let me in with those crazy
people like rhonda say well desantis was
right
the courageous conservative leadership
was right
and the eggheads who followed along with
the liberal establishment
were completely wrong so who's the real
conservative here
you know i got such a kick in 2016 when
mitt romney who is a liberal who
invented obamacare
decided to lecture donald trump on not
being a real conservative
mitt romney whose entire family comes
from the liberal wing of the republican
party right goes all the way back to his
father who ran for president
as a liberal republican mitt romney
carrying on that tradition
what is a real conservative what does
that mean you know i guess if you asked
mitt romney or jeff flake right jeff
like
put these economic questions first i
guess being a good conservative is
giving corporations whatever they want
and always reducing barriers to trade
even if it hurts american workers
and making a lot of money and serving
mammon and not thinking about anything
else is that what's conservative
again mitt romney said he was very
pro-choice remember when he was running
against
ted kennedy for that senate seat he said
that he wasn't a conservative during the
time of reagan bush
he didn't support reagan bush he was an
independent during reagan bush don't
call me a conservative but
for for them now that they pretend to be
the real conservatives
basically just boils down to making more
money for at least some people
donald trump on the other hand who's
considered not a real conservative by
those segments of the right
well he does things a little bit
differently he will go he will do
something that
in the 90s and 2000s you weren't allowed
to do as a conservative
he will criticize corporations
take a listen corporations have given an
enormous amount of money in the tens of
millions or maybe hundreds of millions
to black lives matter
which is all over a lot of these
protests so what does that mean about
these corporations why are they paying
that money out
because they're weak people led by weak
people in many cases not all
corporations what does that mean
i looked at numbers where one company is
giving hundreds of millions of dollars
when you say they're weak what do you
mean because they just
do what's the easiest path that's not
the easy pet that's a very dangerous
path
black lives matter is a marxist
organization
you remember pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon that was the first time i
ever heard of black lives matter
i said that's a terrible name it's so
discriminatory it's bad for black people
it's bad for everybody
and all of a sudden it becomes like sort
of although now if you look it's going
way down because people are tired of
this stuff what's going on
the black lives matter if you look at
what's going on with the bats and the
the a lot of thugs running through dc
last night
oh it's terrible what's going on but
black lives matter came into existence
walking down the street screaming pigs
in a blanket
frying like bacon and that was about
police office that was representing
police
what trump is saying here is that there
is nothing conservative
about allowing corporations to partner
with communists
makes perfect sense to me there's a
segment of the right that would pretend
to be the real conservatives not like
that terrible donald trump who's not
conservative at all
that that segment of the right would say
letting corporations do whatever they
want that's the most conservative
principle
we can't have any barrier to to their
economic success
we can't have any barrier to their
profits gdp is the only measurement of
how conservative a country is
that's right we got even if they're
taking advantage of a lot of legal
loopholes
oh you're partnering with blm
self-described marxists
tearing down statues of george
washington gosh george washington would
love that
oh you'd be making abraham lincoln so
crowd yes burn the country some more as
long as you make the almighty dollar
that's not a compelling argument trump
realizes that that is total bs
that a lot of what has been considered
conservative orthodoxy for the past 30
years 30 40 years
is just ridiculous and there's this idea
that cropped up in the 80s
that among really think tank people and
kind of
conservative libertarians who then
became
a huge influence if not the dominant
influence in the conservative movement
republican
party they said that basically the
essence of conservatism is free trade
i i don't think that's true you know we
trace our our political party back to
abraham lincoln abraham lincoln said
that if you give me a tariff i'll give
you the greatest country in the world
the republican party was founded on
tariffs doesn't mean we should only have
uh protection on trade and we should
totally shut out the rest of the world
nobody's ever said that
but it does mean that we need to
take into account lots of other
calculations beyond gdp
we've got to take into account the
american worker for one we've got to
take into account
american loyalty for another we've got
to take into account
our politics our trading relationships
foreign policy we've got to take into
account
a lot of things and you can't boil
conservatism down
to some silly ideological bullet point
in a manifesto
particularly when the effect of that is
to let
very powerful organizations partner with
people that want to destroy the country
all in the pursuit of a cheap buck trump
gets that that's a deeply conservative
insight
much more conservative than his critics
and it's not just all red meat by the
way it's not just this is one criticism
that people make of trump
they say oh trump he's a populist so he
just
gives the mob whatever the mob wants to
hear and then they'll cheer him on
not so not at all trump was asked you
heard he was on laura ingram's show
there
he was asked about uh conservative
vigilantes you know
for instance that that kid kyle
rittenhouse who
went out and showed up to this left-wing
riot and was attacked
and did defend himself but does that
mean that conservatives should go out
and put themselves in a provocative
situation where maybe they're going to
have to
return the attacks of antifa with some
bullets
trump says far from it do you want your
supporters to confront
the left-wing protesters or do you want
to leave it to law
no i don't want them i want to leave it
to law enforcement but
my supporters are wonderful hard-working
tremendous people
and they turn on their television set
and they look at a portland or they look
at a kenosha before
i got involved and stopped it or they
look at chicago where
78 people were shot last weekend and
numerous people died
or they look at new york where violence
is up by like what 150 percent it's up
by
a number that nobody and people are
leaving they're looking at all of this
and they can't believe it that's right
absolutely right and i gotta tell you i
hate to say i told you so i made this
point on my show a day or two ago
and maybe i made it at the end of last
week and i caught some flack for it in
the comments section because people were
asking about this
kyle rittenhouse case this young
right-wing guy who
who drove about 25 minutes half an hour
to the kenosha riots and he was cleaning
things up but he armed himself because
obviously he was a provocative place
and then he gets attacked by antifa and
he shoots three of them
right he's a very good shot he's a
better shot than these antifa and blm
people
who were attacking him now he's arrested
for murder
and i a lot of people are asking
what how should we think of this and i
said he obviously was acting in
self-defense
but he made an imprudent decision an
unadvisable decision to go to the
left-wing riots
conservatives basically should stay away
from the left-wing riots
they shouldn't put themselves in this
kind of a provocative situation we
should take a lesson from johnny cash
don't take your guns to town son leave
your guns at home bill don't take your
guns to town
in part because of how stacked against
you the entire liberal establishment
and and specifically the liberal legal
establishment will be and the media
and this this left-wing cultural
hegemony i guess you would call it
because of that it is imprudent
to go show up in a place where you're
kind of looking for trouble even if you
want to clean it up
even if you want to stand up to these
guys we have to allow the civil
authority
to take care of that and if the civil
authority isn't going to do that then
well then i suppose we're in a state of
all-out anarchy i don't think we're
quite there yet
obviously it's a different situation if
it's happening in your town in your
neighborhood outside of your building
that's very different than getting in a
car and driving 30 minutes away
conservatives shouldn't be looking to
confront these people that's highly
prudent advice and by the way
prudence is another conservative
principle that has been completely
forgotten in our highly ideolo
ideologized world where so-called
conservatives say that we need to have a
five bullet point manifesto and just
follow that precisely with mathematical
certainty well
james madison says in the federalist
nothing could be more foolish
than to found your regime on perfectly
arithmetical principles
there is a role for prudence for good
judgment saying i remember i actually
loved when trump said this in 2016.
trump was asked about the transgender
bathroom issue
because there there had been laws being
passed saying that
men should use the men's room women
should use the women's room makes
perfect sense then the federal
government came in and said no men need
to be able to use
the women's room they need to be able to
change with the little girls
in the changing rooms and trump was
asked what's your policy on this he said
hold on
we're talking about the very few people
in this country who are men who
think that they're women and they take
hormones and maybe they've had a surgery
to look more like
i don't know what were they doing before
this was never a problem before
seems like it was f it seems like you're
inventing a problem let's maybe just
keep it the way it was
and not make a problem where there isn't
one that advice
irritated left wingers and also
irritated conservatives who wanted some
perfectly crisp policy trump brought
forward
a political virtue called prudence much
much more conservative than some of his
detractors
like romney or those other sorts of
people it's not just trump though
there's another person who's much more
conservative than his detractors we'll
get to that in a second we'll get to mr
yeezy in a second first though i've got
to thank
all of you for going over to the michael
knoll show youtube channel we're now
so close to 200 000 subscribers we
appreciate it we love it when you
subscribe to the daily wire youtube
channel
but much more importantly much more
important than giving ben all those
likes
head on over to the michael noel show
one by the way daily wire is now on
apple tv and roku
so obviously you get the podcast on
youtube and facebook and spotify and all
over the place
probably myspace but now you can get it
on apple tv and roku you can watch it on
the big screen you got to be an insider
member though to watch it live so head
on over dailywire.com
knowles use code watch at checkout
you'll get 15 off your membership
purchase
the deal will not last long we're just
very excited that we're now on the big
screen
so we want to make sure that as many
people can get us there as as
as want to so head on over you will uh
get get to see the shows on the big
screen you'll get a one of a kind
highly coveted leftist tears tumblr
dailywire.com
knowles 15 off with code watch we'll be
right back with a lot more
i don't want to skip too quickly over
this issue of prudence because i think a
lot of conservatives don't even
understand this
burke you know with a great conservative
philosopher he understood this prudence
is really important
making a wise judgment and sometimes
it's not always neat and clean
great example trump was being made fun
of for this yesterday they were calling
him the soup nazi like from seinfeld
because he was describing what these
antifa insurrectionists
what these blm insurrectionists were
doing
they're you know they're throwing mouth
off cocktails they're using bats some of
them have guns
but there's one tactic that is actually
pretty clever to evade
capture they're throwing cans of soup
here's why
and then they have cans of soup soup
and they throw the cans of soup that's
better than a brick because you can't
throw a brick it's too heavy
but a can of soup you can really put
some power into that right
and then when they get caught they say
no this is soup for my family
they're so innocent this is soup for my
family
uh it's incredible and you have people
coming over with bags of soup big bags
of soup
and they lay it on the ground and the
anarchists take it and they start
throwing it
at our cops at our police and if it hits
you that's worse than a brick because
it's got force
it's the perfect size it's like made
perfect
and when they get caught they say no
this is just
soup for my family and then the
media says this is just these people are
very very innocent
they're innocent people these are just
protesters
isn't it wonderful to allow protesting
no
and by the way the media knows it better
than we do they know what's going on i
don't know what's
wrong with them the media do know what's
going on but we don't have an
independent media we don't have
we don't even have separation of powers
because we're actually just governed by
the bureaucracy
but we certainly don't have an
independent media the media are simply
the communications wing of the
democratic party or
you could call it more broadly the
liberal establishment why is he talking
about soup
he's talking about soup because this is
a tactic that
these thugs are using on the streets to
evade
precise laws if they had uh brass
knuckles or something they could just be
arrested for having that weapon if they
were brandishing knives
or if they were brandishing even
baseball bats they could be arrested for
those weapons
but they have the soup so that the
minute the cops say wait a second why
are you why do you have that soup cocked
back
like you're curt chilling or something
you say oh i'm just getting ready to
feed this to my family you can't take
this you can't arrest me
it's a gray area to avoid breaking a law
and what trump is saying is we need to
use prudence we need to realize what
these people are
actually doing not the theory i don't
really care that much about the theory
we care about
the practice what's really going on and
conservatives as a rule
should prefer what what works in
practice
to merely what works in theory you know
another guy who's more conservative than
joe biden or jeff flake for that matter
or a lot of the people we were told were
conservative before the last several
years
kanye west kanye west who oh my gosh
when
kanye first kind of came onto the
political scene started saying political
things
so how many sophisticated conservatives
said oh my gosh stop it
go away kanye we don't want to hear from
you oh kind uh this is so embarrassing
we're fancy people we go to think tanks
and eat boxed lunches
and we sip shabli we we don't need to be
listening from kanye how embarrassing
well guess what turns out kanye west is
more conservative than the vast majority
of elected republicans because he
actually understands what
what the problem is and he's willing to
go places
that a lot of conservatives would not so
you remember nick cannon he was that
kind of
ex-child star i guess he's still on some
tv shows or something nick cannon made
these comments
a few weeks ago where he was he was
criticizing the jews and he was calling
white people animals
and saying they didn't have souls and
really toxic stuff he almost got
canceled for it
except because his racism was directed
to white people and jews it didn't
really stick and i think he was able to
keep
most of his employment so kanye west
decides to go on this show
not to agree with nick cannon but to
show him
issues with his political views and
to to try to bring him over to a more
conservative point of view
and he focused in with brilliant
precision
on planned parenthood
in 50 years there's 20 there's been 22
million
over 22 million 500 000
black people aborted
strategically and on purpose
planned parenthood was set up and placed
in minority
communities to
kill black people you're talking about
uh
when margaret sanger the originator of
planned parenthood at the time
because a lot of people when when you
say things like that to in their defense
they say well
planned parenthood today is a different
organization but
but here we go
here we go margaret sanger the founder
of planned parenthood
was an avowed racist whose goal was to
reduce the black population
in america and she succeeded eighty
percent of abortion clinics
in america are are in minority
neighborhoods over 22 million
five hundred thousand black babies have
been aborted in 50 years
so those numbers are undeniable
statistics i guess
sometimes we can use statistics it when
they when they
serve our purposes but we should be we
should be careful about statistics
because statistics get manipulated by
social scientists but those numbers are
hard to deny
we do know the number of babies who have
been killed we do know that planned
parenthood was strategically placed in
minority neighborhoods we do know that
margaret sanger was a racist
you know obviously that word now has
kind of lost all meaning but whatever
meaning it once had certainly she
qualifies
there's a quote that goes around all the
time for margaret sanger that says we
don't want word to go out that we want
to exterminate the negro population
and what the left responds to that is
they'll say oh she was
she was being ironic in a letter that
she was writing to someone
and there i guess there's some validity
to that there she may have been denying
that even in her quote
but you don't just need to read that
quote read woman in the new race
read all of her other writings she was
an avowed eugenicist
who viewed certain undesirable
populations
as being sub-human and she wanted to
eradicate them and that included
what she viewed to be lesser races and
that included
people who had mental problems who she
suggested be snuffed out through
abortion
all of that is undeniable and
the left obviously doesn't want to talk
about it many people on the right don't
want to talk about it you know fancy
conservatives kanye west is willing to
talk about it
who's more conservative jeff flake or
kanye west
kanye kanye is kanye west is even though
he's got a lot of kooky things that he
says
he's more conservative than i would
estimate 70
of elected republicans in the country
and he's willing to go out and use some
cultural power like another president
that we have who happened to be a tv
star and a
cultural icon like going over and
talking to nick cannon another
former tv star another cultural figure
willing to engage on that level that's a
very conservative thing to do
and what's the alternative what's the
alternative you know we've been joking
about all the conspiracy theories going
around the internet trump was asked
about this they said do you believe in
these conspiracy theories
they said what conspiracy theory because
the theory is that there's a satanic
group of pedophiles
cannibals that are trying to destroy the
country i thought like well satanic
let's see the left is uh burning down
churches
and pedophiles they're i just saw a
photo
of bill clinton hanging out with jeffrey
epstein getting a massage
and cannibals i saw risa ashley i need
human brains on cnn
yeah sounds about right yeah sound i
don't is that a conspiracy theory i can
name all the people who are doing those
things
in any case you look at these little
blips right the jet the epstein thing
was one where you thought gosh this
pedophile thing is a little weird then
you look
at that that show that just went on
netflix this movie called cuties
which talked about how an 11 year old
discovers her love of twerking
and decides to to break up with her
family
because her family's too traditional and
she wants to go twerk with her other
pre-teen friends
i think that's weird very sexualized
poster
now in the state of california the left
wants to legalize pederasty
heterostate sexual relations between
grown men
and young boys they want to legalize it
i know that sounds impossible
but it's real it's called sb 145
and it just passed by the way just it's
not even like it was some
random pervert who who just proposed it
and it was shot down
the 40-member state senate in california
by a vote of 23 to 10
just passed sb 145 which was
a bill introduced by california state
senator scott weiner
we have to stop electing people named
weiner they they always
they always live up to the silliness of
their name
scott weiner is from san francisco
you'll be surprised
under sb 145 if a
if an adult has gay sex with a minor
14 years or older and that adult is 10
years
is less than 10 years older than the
person
a judge will have the discretion on
whether or not to
uh place the individual on the sex
offender registry
so to put that in an example you have a
23 year old guy
who has sex with a 14 year old boy
that is not necessarily a sex crime that
person will not necessarily
be put on the sex offender registry
there might be some other smaller
punishments but to actually register as
a sex offender
no longer have to do that
that's weird what why are we why why is
that a
bill that's creepy and perverted and
weird
and and obviously deeply wrong how
on earth did that get through the
california state senate voting for the
party
as jeff flake suggests we do voting for
the party that is now
actively pushing to legalize pederasty
is that conservative
i guess it's conservative in the sense
that it harkens all the way back to
ancient greece
hurricanes back to you know ancient
athens and socrates and things like that
but that
that's a little too conservative for me
okay if we're just looking at time
scales here
i'd rather stick maybe around 1776 is
okay
in the american tradition that's some
radical stuff though
and you're not going to hear about that
in the mainstream media but that is the
extent of it
i'll give you i'll give you one more
example before we go this one i guess
it's not as
creepy as as the pederasty thing in
california but it's
it's in some ways even more radical
a commission that was just created by
the mayor of washington dc
has recommended changes to a ton of
public buildings
and monuments they want to remove thomas
jefferson's name from federal buildings
but that that's not even the most
ridiculous one they want to remove
the washington monument the washington
monument
from washington dc named
after the father of our country
this established by the mayor of
washington dc
which by the way is a ridiculous office
that should not exist
the district of columbia is a federal
district it's not
a state it's not some separate
territory that's not under the control
of the federal government it's under the
control of the federal government it
should be governed by the federal
government
they should not have votes in washington
d.c they should have a representative
in washington dc it's not a state it's a
federal district there should not be a
mayor of washington d.c
it's the nation's capital it's our place
i
i don't think we should defer on
government to the residents of
washington dc
probably there shouldn't be permanent
residents of washington d.c they should
live in maryland or virginia from which
we
get washington d.c now you've got
the mayor of our national capital trying
to tear down
our singular national monument
that's pretty radical that's pretty
radical and you know
how did they arrive at this well they
took a survey did a town hall they had
meetings with residents
and the committee said this committee in
washington dc
said that 80 of washington residents
support a push to quote
remove or rename assets where the
namesake's legacy was inconsistent with
or did not align with the district's
core values of equity opportunity and
prosperity
another great example of lies damned
lies in statistics the word statistics
comes from the word of the state
right this is an invention of
progressives who want more and more
state
statist power which is why generally
speaking we should ignore statistics
but the survey was done of washington dc
residents i don't care what washington
dc residents
think i don't care it's not it's not
their district
it's all of our district it's the it's a
federal district
that represents the entire country
and now they want to tear down the
washington monument
washington dc mayor will be shocked to
find out as a democrat
jeff flake says ah these democrats
they're more conservative than donald
trump
are they is that is tearing down the
washington monument conservative
a bunch of fake conservatives seem to
think so and if they're wrong on that if
they're wrong and so central a question
what else have they been wrong about
maybe it's time to rethink
conservatism hopefully we can rethink it
before they tear down
the washington monument that's our show
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing
the end of days is approaching and the
moon has turned to blood but on the
andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton